[Music]
there's a factory inside you that weighs
about 1.4 kilograms and runs for 24
hours a day this is your liver the
heaviest organ in your body and one of
the most crucial this industrious
structure simultaneously acts as a
storehouse a manufacturing hub and a
processing plant and each of these
functions involves so many important
subtasks that without the liver our
bodies would simply stop working one of
the livers main functions is to filter
the body's blood which it receives in
regular shipments from two sources the
hepatic artery delivers blood from the
heart while the hepatic portal vein
brings it from the intestine this double
delivery fills the liver with nutrients
that it then sorts processes and stores
with the help of thousands of tiny
internal processing plants known as
lobules
both blood flows also deliver the oxygen
that the liver needs to function the
blood that is received from the
intestine contains carbohydrates fats
and vitamins and other nutrients
dissolved in it from the food you've
consumed these must be processed in
different ways in the case of
carbohydrates the liver breaks them down
and converts them into sugars for the
body to use as energy when the filtered
blood is sent back out sometimes the
body has leftovers of nutrients that it
doesn't immediately require when that
happens the liver holds some back and
stacks them in its storage facility this
facility works like a pantry for future
cases when the body might be in need of
nutrients but the blood flowing into the
liver isn't always full of good things
it also contains toxins and byproducts
that the body can't use and the liver
monitors these strictly when it spots a
useless or toxic substance it either
converts it into a product that can't
hurt the body or isolates it and whisks
it away channeling it through the
kidneys and intestine to be excreted of
course we wouldn't consider the liver a
factory if it didn't also manufacture
things
organ makes everything from various
blood plasma proteins that transport
fatty acids and help form blood clots to
the cholesterol that helps the body
create hormones it also makes vitamin B
and substances that help digestion but
one of its most vital products is the
bile like an eco-friendly treatment
plant the liver uses cells called
hepatocytes to convert toxic waste
products into this bitter greenish
liquid as its produced bile is funneled
into a small container below the liver
called the gall bladder before being
trickled into the intestine to help
break down fats destroy microbes and
neutralize extra stomach acid bile also
helps carry other toxins and byproducts
from the liver out of the body so as you
can see the liver is an extremely
efficient industrial site performing
multiple tasks that support each other
but such a complex system needs to be
kept running smoothly by keeping it
healthy and not overloading it with more
toxins than it can handle this is one
factory we simply can't afford to shut
down
you
[Music]